hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled varicella zoster virus
the vzv one pathogen with multiple
clinical manifestations
this webinar is part of the 2021
microbiology virtual week and i am susie
valdez of labyrinths and i will be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab roots and sponsored by dsorin
molecular for more information about our
sponsor please go to
molecular.diastorm.com
so let's get started before we begin i
want to remind everyone that this event
is interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you would like during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation
and if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation just click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen
as a reminder this presentation is
educational and offers free continuing
education credits
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right
hand corner of your presentation window
and follow the process to obtain those
credits
i now present today's speaker dr preeti
pontilli director of clinical
microbiology and professor of clinical
pathology at the ohio state university
wexner medical center for complete
biography of our speakers please visit
the biography tab at the top right of
your screen dr patrolli welcome you may
now begin your presentation hello
everybody um it's my pleasure today to
give this talk um it's a very
interesting topic on herpes viruses and
vzb in particular
i am sure we've all encountered herpes
viruses in our lifetime either our
directly ourselves
with our people that we know on our
patient population
so it's my pleasure to um to discuss
this very interesting topic with all of
you today
so i'd like to start with an outline for
the human herpes viruses and then
you know go straight into the vzv
aspects which is the main gist of my
talk today
so five facts about human herpes viruses
that i'm sure you're all very familiar
with
one is that it's a large genome of
double-stranded
linear dna that is part and parcel of
the herpes viruses
these viruses can establish latent
infections
and can be extreme viral shedders as in
vzv hsv that we are aware that we are
very familiar with
and there are several uh herpes viruses
that are known however uh only nine uh
routinely infect humans
um and these are associated with a wide
range of clinical infections that
include you know dermal genital ocular
cns organ systems etc so wide variety
and then once infected
the human herpes viruses stay latent
which means they pretty much never leave
you in the apartment parcel um you know
of i guess they just sort of learn to
live live with you
so these are um the nine herpes viruses
um that infect humans and and they're
listed here um from one through eight
and there are two hhv-6
viruses
and as you can see that um close to 100
of adult populations are infected with
at least one of these viruses so you can
see how ubiquitous these viruses are
and
once infected
one is infected for life
so there are different subfamilies of
these viruses
the alpha viruses subfamily that
targets the neurons
whereas the beta and the gamma viruses
are shown here now i don't have a
pointer so we're just going to have to
follow along the slide
uh the beta and the gamma they target
the leukocytes
so there is this propensity of targeting
these
these different anatomic sites
now in terms of
symptoms and disease conditions they are
very varied
shown here is herpes
hhv
1 and 2 which is hypersimplex virus 1 2
and vzv you can see we get cold sores
general herpes chickenpox shingles
and then if you just go down the list of
these viruses you can start to see there
are several other manifestations with
the remaining human herpes viruses
now a lot
many times
some of these viruses they are usually
asymptomatic
which means that they do not cause
disease right up front
some do of course when you have a
coarser or gentle herpes one is
symptomatic
however
they as i mentioned that they do remain
latent
in the body and can reactivate
um later in life as a result of an
immune compromised condition
old age or something to that effect that
can lead to this reactivation of these
viruses
so this transmission that occurs primary
infection uh latency
and then reactivation um at some point
if these are to be reactivating
now it was really interesting to see
this article in new york post about
human herpes viruses in the news
in association with nasa astronauts
so we know that human herpes viruses
have co-evolved uh with with the human
being
and they have been a part of our life
for very very long time
so it should come as no surprise that
this study that was conducted that was
published in frontiers in microbiology
by this group
they actually studied human herpes
viruses in astronauts
that were going that was during the
shuttle flight a short flight 10 to 16
days or international space station
flight that lasted for greater than 180
days
and they took samples from these
astronauts prior to the flight and then
also during the flight specimens were
collected different body fluids were
collected and then post flight
and they measured uh different herpes
viruses um in these specimens from the
astronauts
and what they found was interestingly
that uh these viruses were detected uh
the herpes viruses were detected in
these astronauts so about 53 percent of
the astronauts in the shuttle flights
were positive and 61 of the astronauts
from the international space space
station flight were also positive
so these were being shed in in their uh
body fluids
and some of these were even cultured
on tissue culture which means that these
were live viruses
and interestingly they also measured
stress hormones in these
in these astronauts and shown that they
were related to high levels of stress
hormones that were also measured at the
same time
so
um you know we talk about these being
latent and and the fact that they can be
um
you know expressed um
during during stress as well
so i'm sure my stress levels today i'm
just wondering internally myself if any
of these viruses are being activated
as a result of this presentation but
maybe not
so
just talking about epidemiology
of this infection of the herpes viruses
we know it has a very wide
distribution
about 95 percent of adults
have been infected with one or the other
of the herpes viruses
and just looking at uh hsb1 vzv eb ebv
we know geographic distribution is about
80 to 90 percent um pretty much all over
the world
with cmv
we see a socio-economic status where
fifty percent um we find cmv and fifty
percent of our folks in western europe
and ninety percent in african and asian
countries
uh with regards hsv type two uh it
ranges from twenty to 70 percent and
again based on race and age
um so women are
have more propensity to get hsb2 and
also in terms of race uh non-caucasian
blacks are more prone to hsv too perhaps
i'll show higher prevalence of hsv2
now with regards to transmission of
human herpes viruses we can see this
nice pictorial here that talks about
transmission occurring as a result of
airborne transmission
person-to-person transmission closed
contact
vertical from mother to baby and then
also transplanted organs and blood
transfusions so there are just several
modalities by which one can acquire
these herpes viruses
now lab diagnostics is obviously very
key and something very dear to my heart
since i'm a clinical microbiologist
so we have several different methods of
detecting herpes viruses viral culture
which used to be something we used to
rely on a lot previously
envirocultures are are still very useful
especially if one needs to do
antiviral resistance studies
we like to be able to cultivate the
virus but there are other modalities
like antigen detection direct
fluorescent antibody staining
from a lesion that is infected that can
be stained directly
then there is pcr which is considered a
gold standard for detecting
human herpes viruses especially in the
cerebrospinal fluid and cns infections
and then there is of course the
histopathological
diagnostics looking for a tissue
biopsies and retinal changes as well
now uh with that broad introduction from
for human herpes virus we'll switch now
to talking about vzv
now vcv i just wanted to just go over a
few pointers in terms of just some
historical perspectives
uh chickenpox was not distinguished from
smallpox until the end of 19th century
and in 1875 steiner demonstrated that
chickenpox was caused by an infectious
organism because he took some of the
material and inoculated volunteers with
the vesicular fluid from patients and
they developed acute varicella
so that was interesting i guess these
are things we could you know that were
done in during that era
and then later on in 1888 juan bouquet
he observed a clinical relationship
between varicella and herpes zaster
whereby
children that did not have any evidence
of varicella immunity they acquired
varicella
after contact with a herpes zoster case
and uh finally in 1954 vz was actually
isolated from vesicular fluid in tissue
culture by thomas beller so you can see
it's not so long ago really that we
was actually you know cultured in the
lab and identified as a causative agent
for for these infections
so just getting more into the vzv we
know it's a human herpes virus 3 we know
it's a very ubiquitous virus because a
large number of people are infected with
this virus in fact
greater than 90 of the world population
is infected
we talked about it being a
double-stranded dna genome virus
so it targets the t lymphocytes
epithelial cells and then likes to stay
latent in the in the ganglia and the
sensory ganglion
and transmission occurs through
respiratory droplets or direct contact
with skin lesions
and interestingly it has two different
forms of disease
one during early childhood or chickenpox
which is generally a self-limiting
disease it's highly contagious and
results in itchy blister-like rash on
the skin
and then a secondary infection
which is called shingles as a result of
reactivation of the virus later on in
life
after having acquired primary infection
and it affects mostly adults and we have
about a million cases in the u.s per
year
now the virus itself the vis-a-vis virus
itself is a circular virus
and is
and has the structure shown on the left
hand side
uh it comprises of a core region which
is a genetic double-stranded dna
and it has a capsid which is a protein
coat that surrounds the genetic material
then that's followed by a tegument which
is the part between the virus
and the cat the capsid and the envelope
it's a layer in between and this
contains all the enzymes
replicating inside the host cell
and then finally there is the envelope
that you see on the outside with those
little spikes on it and this envelope is
uh made up of modified host cell
membrane and they're viral glycoproteins
and these glycoproteins actually are
what helps target it to the neural cells
so they're receptors that bind to these
glycoproteins
so just talking a little bit about vzv
replication
so you can see here is a virus
that is entering the cell
and it attaches to the cell it gets
internalized
and it fuses and uncoats and then the
dna then enters inside the nucleus
whereby it then circularizes
and then um
and then starts to replicate
and it also produces immediate early
proteins or late proteins as a result of
this replication
and then it does assemble
with the with the nucleocapsid protein
uh the dna then forms these
these structures which are then butted
outside of the nucleus they come into
the cytoplasm and then
go for the maturation and assembly uh to
become the fully formed uh virus
particle that is then released to the
outside of the cell so vcv does not
integrate into the host chromosome like
the retroviruses or adenoviruses rather
it's maintained as an extra chromosomal
circular
episome inside the nucleus and that's
just pretty much how it likes to stay
latent inside the cell
so vcv as we mentioned is highly
infectious virus and greater than 90
percent of individuals show serological
evidence which means that they have been
infected in the past
and during prior to the development of
the vaccine the availability of the
vaccine farasala used to have the right
of passage in children it meant that you
know large number of children will get
infected or people will get infected
with with this virus
and in the early 1990s um there was um
you know an average of four million
people um you know getting getting the
varicella
large numbers being hospitalized between
10 to 13 000 being hospitalized and then
about 100 250 that died each year
after the availability of the varicella
vaccine that started in the united
states in 1995 there was greater than 90
reduction in morbidity and mortality so
this vaccine is highly efficacious and
really helped
decrease the disease burden
so talking about vaccination for vcv
this is really a feat and
[Music]
just something that we know is really
important in preventing disease
so vaccination was offered in the united
states in 1995 as i mentioned it was
offered earlier in japan and korea but
we had our doses available in 1995
and there are two different distinct
vaccination modalities one that's given
early in life to
children
first dose is given at 12 months
um and then the second dose is given at
four to six years and this is with a
live attenuated virus a vaccine that's
produced by merck uh it's the ochre
strain
and then this vaccine has also been
combined with the measles mumps rubella
and varicella as part of that
vaccination so that can be delivered
along with the is as a combined vaccine
so you can see that with the second dose
you have about greater than 98
protection
so it's really highly efficacious
and then
there is a second vaccine that is the
shingles vaccine that is given
to adults and shingress is given to
adults greater than 50 years of age it's
a recombinant non-life vaccine and is
given in two doses two to six months
apart
it's also highly effective it's 97
effective and more recently i was very
interested to note that it's also
recently been approved in july of this
year july 2021 in immune compromised
individuals greater than 18 years so so
that is really good news to know that
there is something available for a
younger age population immune compromise
situation
then the other one is the
is the zostavax virus which is a live
attenuated virus given to individuals
greater than 60 years age
it's the same vaccine that's given to
children early in life it's just the
dose is much higher so it's about 14
times higher dose
and it is it leads to about 50 reduction
in shingles
but it's not approved for immune
compromised individuals
so it's just like i said a very
important step towards
eradicating this disease or towards
helping um
against this disease
so now we want to just get into a little
bit of the pathogenesis and clinical
presentation of weezy v
we know it's highly contagious it's
spread by direct contact
you know or inhalation of droplets of
aerosols from vesicular fluids
so here is day zero where it enters into
the respiratory tract and conjunctiva
the virions are then inhaled and then
they enter
via this and the mucous membranes so
that's step number one
after that
there is replication of the of the virus
inside the body and there is um so there
is replication that occurs in the
nasopharynx and the regional lymph nodes
and then it also uh reaches the lungs
now at that stage now we are at day four
and six primary vibramia results whereby
infected t cells
are carrying the virus are now able to
carry the virus to
other parts of the body
so on day six four to six the infected t
cells um you know
now
move the virus and there's additional
replication and dissemination involving
other organ systems like the liver
spleen the sensory ganglia
so and then there is a secondary viremia
that occurs
which is again part and parcel of the
whole
virus
replication whereby now the infection
can um can feed the skin
so the whole incubation period and the
development of skin lesions you know
takes about 14 days to 20 days
for the skin lesions to appear
so this shows you
the varicella the chickenpox primary
infection
so in healthy children it's generally
mild and self-limited
you can see that it starts
the chicken pox starts you know um maybe
in the scalp region and the torso and
then develops on the sides so it's a
it's a it's a really good clinical
diagnostics um for for our physicians to
be able to recognize the distribution of
this um of of this uh varicella
uh there's malaise associated fever
associated with this that lasts for two
to three days and then a large number of
lesions about 200 to 500 lesions um you
know and they can come up in different
crops of two to three crops with uh 200
to 500 lesions and these lesions you
know are in different states of
maturation uh generally some of them are
more active and the others crusting so
that you can definitely observe
different um
stages of of of these
lesions
and if someone were to get varicella
during adult life it tends to be more
severe
as compared to that acquired during
childhood
so in terms of incidents of chickenpox
uh we have about 13 to 16 cases per 1000
persons per year
and complications about two to six
percent of the acute complications
so worldwide we have about 140 million
cases and there's about 4.2 million
severe complications that occur
worldwide and about 4 000 cases
of death associated with varicella
chickenpox
so one of the hallmark features of of
of this disease is lifelong latency as
we discussed previously which is true
for all
all human herpes viruses so
after primary infection occurs
the
infection travels from the skin cells
the virions they travel to the sensory
nerve cells because of the glycoprotein
that is uh the mano6 phosphate that is
located in the viral envelope
glycoprotein it has a corresponding
receptor in nerve cells and so now the
virus makes its way into into these
ganglion these
nerve cells and then
stay latent there and have the
propensity to stay late in there for a
very long time in the dorsal root
ganglion
now the virus stays there for a very
long time unless and until there is a
there is a decrease in cell mediated
immunity either as a result of immune
compromised
nature um or some sort of immune
compromising situation or old age etc
and that's when reactivation can occur
from latency
and then the spread of and then the
infection restarts in the form of
shingles
so this i thought was a really good
pictorial that sort of puts it in
perspective um you know the primary
infection with varicella on the left
hand side here that we talked about how
the infection occurs and then the
latency
of the virus whereby from the skin it
moves into the neuronal axon spinal cord
and the lys latent in the in dorsal root
ganglion
and then later in life it can result in
disaster whereby
you know the virus from the dorsal root
ganglion now makes its way back
into the into the um skin in the form of
dermatomes um you know as a form of
shingles or zoster
so this sort of just really puts it in
perspective
now talking about shingles which is
reactivation of the of the herpes
viruses
um it is generally seen in aging or
immune suppression
it's not necessarily true that it's only
related to old age or older population
aging population
greater than 60 years old there is a 10
8 to 10 fold increase in that population
so there are about 1 million cases a
year have as we discussed previously
and that obviously leads to
a lot of cost health care costs
now in terms of lifelong
risk of getting zoster is estimated to
be 32
and
50 of the people living until the age of
85 uh will likely develop zoster uh
especially if they're not if they're not
vaccinated
um so i just wanted to reiterate the
fact that it's not just only associated
with with uh with the aging population i
did have a colleague um and we were in
our 20s um in our and and she was going
to be having her thesis
defense coming up and
she was pretty stressed and ended up
with having shingles pretty much halfway
down her face
which was just
very uh odd
only because we generally tend to think
of this as a as a disease that gets
reactivated later in life but i guess it
can happen
um at any age
so i'm just talking about shingles again
the main symptoms for shingles is
obviously the blistery
itchy rash but you also have um you know
this
very a painful situation that is called
the post-herpetic neuralgia or phn that
develops
the rash is there for two to four weeks
but the p and h or the post-stabilic
neuralgia can last much longer
so in terms of reactivation uh with the
post-herpetic neuralgia this just shows
you a little pictorial here
of how painful and debilitating
nerve pain
can can occur
and that
can last actually a few weeks to to a
year two years actually
and can affect one in five individuals
that have shingles so it's something
really important to to keep in mind
now this uh
graph here on the right uh shows you um
the the complications of with
post-herpetic neuralgia that occur as a
result of um as a result of age and sex
so you can see both sexes are affected
uh with the phn and as one gets older in
life there is more propensity to have
the postherpetic neuralgia the incidence
is higher
so about in 80 plus years age the
incidence is 33
as compared to
18
if someone is 50 50 plus years old
so it increases in propensity in an
older population
now in terms of complications of vcv in
general with varicella which is a
primary infection and if varicella
occurs in a healthy child there should
be really not too many complications
because the immune system
you know takes care of that but in rare
cases where there is complications you
can see all these different conditions
that are listed here complications with
bacterial sepsis pneumonia encephalitis
etc
that can
occur uh with zaster
that is occurring after latency and a
reactivation um you know you can also
get
many different complications uh with
zoster
and this includes bengal encephalitis
cranial nerve pulses myelitis hepatitis
pancreatitis etc so these complications
can be quite severe
as a result of vcv infection
so people uh that are of a higher risk
for severe uh vcv infections are listed
are shown here um so we have solid organ
transplant recipients um so it's mainly
immune compromised uh individuals adults
greater than 65 years or older
pregnant women without a evidence of
immunity to varicella
immune compromised people with leukemia
or lymphopenia or on medications
children less than 13 years of age and
also premature babies so you can see
there's a wide list of people
with high risk of vcv infections
now vdv can also
uh affect um you know uh the eyes uh
with herpes zoster
or thalamicus
uh whereby the optic nervous is impacted
uh there can be vision loss uh with that
and then also can lead to permanent
blindness in severe situations
we also have the ramsey hunt syndrome uh
whereby
a part of the year is affected which can
lead to hearing loss um and and and also
muscle paralysis
uh hearing loss as a ramsey hunt
syndrome so given these things are not
very common uh however they they
certainly can occur
now in terms of neurological
complications of wheezy are this is
something of great concern and i wanted
to spend a little bit of time um
describing these um in this slide and
the next few slides
so complications neurological
complications occur in one to three uh
per ten thousand cases that may not
sound like a lot however if you consider
that greater than
population is infected with vzv
that does add up
so in terms of common complications uh
neurological complications there is
encephalitis and then they can also be
aseptic meningitis
cerebral ataxia
as depicted here on the right hand side
so several different neurological
complications can occur
so what is really interesting that we
often discuss is like
how a virus that causes no more than a
cold sore in one person can actually
produce fatal encephalitis in another
so this is just a very interesting
question it's a very interesting
immunological pathological uh question
with a host immune response and the
virus interaction and the same can be
posed for covet infection as to such a
diverse manifestation of symptoms but
this is really an enigma and something
that a lot of researchers are working on
to answer
so
in this particular uh pictorial um i
wanted to
just show the dorsal root ganglion which
is the latency site
whereby we know that the virus
likes to likes to stay latent
now
in both an immune compromise and immune
competent individuals they can be
reactivation at some point in in one's
life
and depending on the direction that the
virus reactivate activates whether it
goes towards the spinal cord
or the cnf or the brain or whether it
goes um centrifugally towards the skin
or centro centripetally towards the
towards the brain spinal cord so it
really depends on what path
uh the virus uh takes that can lead to
uh activation reactivation of the virus
so this pretty much i thought this was a
nice pictorial uh that shows you the
dorsal ganglion and then the different
pathways
that the that the virus can take so this
is also important to understand that if
the reactivation occurs in the spinal
cord and the brain cells it's not always
necessary that they have to be
um you know manifestations in the in the
in the skin so there may not be any rash
associated if the virus simply decides
to travel um into the brain and the
spinal cord so that's why making the cns
uh diagnostics a little bit more tricky
in the absence of rash
so here are some neurological
complications of vcv we talked about
viral encephalitis and viral aseptic
meningitis so listed on the left hand
side is viral encephalitis
which is the most common type of
encephalitis and caused by viruses and
listed here is vcv that is causes 15 to
23 percent of of these viral
encephalitis cases about 18 000 cases
per year
as compared to viral aseptic meningitis
on the right hand side and you can see
vzv along with enteroviruses and other
herpes viruses can also be asso can also
cause the viral aseptic meningitis and
there are a total of about 4 600 cases a
year in the united states
and this can lead to either you know
severe complications permanent brain
damage and encephalitis or short-term
memory loss etc
during aseptic meningitis
so switching gears a little bit and
talking about diagnosis and detection
so diagnosis and detection we talked
about in our previous slide whereby we
have uh
culture
uh we have dfa direct personal antibody
antigen detection we have pcr we have
histopathological
things to do
now culture is not so great for vcv
because we know that the virus is very
labile doesn't culture very well and
doesn't last outside the host for very
long
and also diagnosing breakthrough
varicella or diagnos diagnosing rashes
in general whether they're breakthrough
whether herpes
rash is is very hard
to do just by looking at the rash
so one of the easiest way to look at
diagnosing varicella varicellis by doing
pcr of the skin lesions as the preferred
test
we know it's easily implemented we know
it's less invasive than drawing blood um
and that the specimens need to be
collected from lesions generally we want
to be able to get specimens early on
infections collected within five days of
the rash onset because that's where you
have a large replication of virus
occurring
and vesicles are preferred over
crosstalk crusted lesions because again
the viral loads are higher there
but a good rub on the macule or a papule
uh
rash uh it could be still sufficient to
get an answer
and you generally want to collect about
greater or equal to two lesions just to
be able to get a good specimen and we
know there's a you know really good
correlation of sensitivity by doing pcr
from the skin lesions
now what becomes tricky is when you're
trying to do vzv cns and sections you're
trying to get
you know diagnostics for that now we
know there are challenges because
when somebody has a cns a manifestation
you want to be able to look into is that
infectious are not infectious
with the infectious entities obviously
we want to be able to find out what they
are they're bacterial are they viral
now with the vcvcns manifestations
it can we know that these manifestations
can occur either as a result of primary
infection or reactivation of the vcv so
in both of these entities cns can be
involved
and then with the cns
complications we know that
these complications can occur
without having a detectable lesion uh or
a zoster rash in individuals so that
makes it a little bit difficult
clinically to diagnose these infections
without having good diagnostics on hand
so thereby rapid diagnostics for these
type of manifestations are critically
important
so looking at the encephalitis
diagnostic guidelines
that are out there for all of us to
review um
it's uh it's along with hsv you can see
that vzv is also indicated as a virus
that should be looked for
in these encephalitis cases
and pcr is preferred um is a is a
preferred test to do for these virus
infections hsv vcv as well
so it is recommended that a css sample
be obtained and then
these pcr assays are highly sensitive
and specific and they have a very fast
turnaround time and require only a
minimal amount of csf specimen
and should be carried out as soon as
possible
and in the absence of a pcr being
positive one can also look for vcv
specific antibodies in the csf that can
be utilized as well
likewise for meningitis we want to be
able to distinguish viral meningitis
caused by hsv vzv enterovirus arbor
viruses from those caused by bacterial
agents it's really important uh to to to
differentiate these because again that
will reduce um the use of antibiotics it
decreases the length of stay prevents
further spread of the infection getting
these diagnostics squared away and
within the viral meningitis panel as you
can see along with herpes and
enteroviruses there's also vzv that
should be looked at
again by pcr
or by dfa
or by zhang smear but obviously pcr of
the csf is the preferred approach
uh now in terms of the different assays
that are available uh for
for um for vzv um infection uh there are
several um that are available
commercially so i've listed the ones
that that are out there
one of which is the biofire which is the
meningitis encephalitis panel it
contains 14 bacterial viral yeast
pathogens all combined in a multiplex
format and the sample here is csf um
and then we have uh quadell assays the
lyra hsv 1 and 2 and vzv combined in the
solana assays
and here they're looking for hsv
and vzv together and the samples is
cutaneous and
much cutaneous swap specimens
so as you can see sometimes it's hard to
differentiate
you know hsv from vzv
hence the need for having a combined
assay
that can look for both of these entities
and then there's the dsrn molecular
assay symplexa assay
which is the vcb direct assay for csf
and there's a vzv swab direct assay that
does cutaneous and mucocutaneous swabs
so that covers a wide range of different
sample types
and they're all fda approved
fda is cleared
so in the form of a summary we know that
vcv causes varicella uh chickenpox and
also herpes zoster which is shingles
uh vcv is highly contagious and can be
spread
to others very easily
but since the virus is shed from the
varicella or from the zoster infections
it can be spread by person to person
contact
or by inhalation of aerosols from
vesicular fluids from the skin lesions
and also through respiratory secretions
so several different ways and
so this is this just definitely requires
isolation in the hospital if somebody's
suspected of vcv
vcv central nervous system can have
various manifestations various
presentations including encephalitis
meningitis
and identifying vcv becomes critically
important in these individuals
to prevent morbidity and mortality
and especially more challenging in these
patients if they present without a rash
uh we talked about vcv
csf pcr as being a pivotal playing a
pivotal role in making rapid and
accurate diagnostics which are very
essential for for treatment of bcv
and then finally we talked about also
the weezy vaccines as being very
effective in preventing disease sequela
for both the
primary chicken pox and also
shingles
disease
so with this
i will stop and take any questions
thank you for your attention